quando vai a fare la corsetta mattutina
ci sono meno 20 gradi fuori porta di una
[ __ ] io come cazzo esco faccio allora
ragazzi di tutti state condonate eco
bruttissimo il video che state per
vedere l'ho girato quando lo sul set di
social facebook ciao
tutto perfetto contento che piove
[ __ ] di una [ __ ] ma non a lei
dichiarò scherza mantenersi in forma e
bruttissimo ragazzi soprattutto io che
ho bisogno di dimagrire allora ragazzi
miei volevo dirvi che quando ero sul set
di social face
ho registrato delle challenge alcune di
queste challenger me ne sono fatte dare
in modo tale da caricarle sul canale ok
quindi ragazzo ci vedrete ben due
challenge che abbiamo fatto che avremmo
assoluto quel tizio a caso allora
ragazzi la prima challenge che vedrete
si chiama tirati luogo in testa e fai
attenzione anche non esploda challenge
buona visione
[Musica]
che schifo la molta roba si vuole che
per i cani jeremy state queste cose sane
l'analisi della gara l'albero dell'ex
cui viene dalla palma delle chiuse ex
ragazzo solare che arriva a 3 uova
all'interno del cesto vince a temi
lanciarlo avrò mai a liszt academy
lanciare alle poi schiacciare
all'interno del centro
io devo fare il mio degli altri lasciare
il tuo si arrivi a 36 salvo per 3 1 2 2
3 1
i fatti li ha dentro sono maturati nei
22 aiutami chiede di leggere un giorno
lo chiamavano mai faccia battere quanto
di solito c'è il duomo
[Musica]
ma veramente questo è un bravo
giocoliere comunque guarda carta ora
sono bravo
[Musica]
e che fluisce da un cavillo 25 io ei
ragazzi invece la seconda challenge
consiste nel resistere il più possibile
a mangiare dei peperoncini piccanti ma
forte porca [ __ ]
ricordo ancora purtroppo niente buona
visione
[Musica]
praga praga mio zio aurelio ma appunto
tutta la calabria di peperoncini quindi
io ho inventato una sfida il gioco e
così devi scegliere se la carta è rossa
o nera
se indovini tu non mangi il peperoncino
e lo mangiano gli avversari non sbagli
regole le truppe di mangiarlo to perde
chi beve per primo il latte quindi
volendo tu potresti mangiarti di tutti e
vincere rosso
avevo già perso all'inizio ci chiedono
con cura ma nemmeno big ma io non me ne
intendo ce l'hai fatta tu stato insieme
però dai alla vostra ragazzi morso kimi
e così il russo di cattiveria dai
ragazzi
[Musica]
evidente stefanino ma noi ha mangiato un
pezzettino di possibilità che esca di
nuovo in rosso sono più basse che esca
il nero però io sono rosso e quindi
gioco sul russo per me è rosso no no no
no scelgo io non scendo io non ci credo
dai è piccolino noia noia
secondo me è rosso a smistare si mangia
e dello scempio io mangio 16 forgiato
nelle fiamme di mordor morti già fatto
come rosso
[Musica]
forti
legame norma che regola di un fondo ju
ju ve lo sa già che andò morendo gira
ancora rosso si becca la meta meta meta
tutto lo staff erbini regate
lk mi levante a capaccio correndo basta
ai violenti ha bevuto posa nero si goda
troppo va già sto peperoncino o no h
schifosa non so se ve ne siete accorti
il grosso è vero se non basta
cross
ma è rimasto male che ci siamo arresi
prima non ci ho rimesso nero
io sono due di lala niente era scontato
che non vincevo io io io come tocco il
piccante con la lingua muoio son per
terra quindi ragazzuoli spero che video
vi sia piaciuto
io concludo qui perché se non mi prendo
tre apple e niente ragazzi quindi spero
che vi sia piaciuto una serie di fiducia
al momento non mi piace anche a pace di
facebook come il video trattare al
kitsch 50.000 laica almeno solo perché
sono uscito fuori a farla intro con la
pioggia che mi rende più rincoglionito
di quanto non lo sia già
vabbè da ragazzi
pilato
la dura vita delle web style dopo il
boom della prima stagione ci rimettono
la faccia social face tutti i lunedì e
giovedì alle 19 25 solo su sky uno